I tried to hear everything that's
happening and that that can be very,
very difficult.
And,
and someone who tells you,
Oh,
I hear everything that's happening on
stage is lying cause there's,
there's almost no way I think to really
do that.
But as an exercise,
I do try to identify,
okay,
what does that musician,
the third flute playing?
And I tried to make sure I can hear
that,
but you have to hear what's going on
because if you're,
there's a way I,
I've used the analogy,
it's like it's like a ball,
a very big ball.
You can affect the way the ball rolls
and you can change the direction that
the ball is rolling if it's already is,
if it's already in motion,
but you can't suddenly have a turn,
an abrupt angle.
There's a natural way that the,
the ball can be guided.
So even though you're steering the ball,
there's a natural momentum that the ball
has that you can't interfere with.
So if the orchestra has a certain flow,
you can affect the flow.
But there's a natural way to do that.
And there's a way that actually would
interrupt the natural flow.
So it's not that you can just do
whatever you want.
You have to take into account what is
happening and what is being offered from
the players.
So that means really being in touch with
what they're doing and hearing them as
well as you can.
And it's surprisingly difficult to,
to really identify not even with two or
three or four lines,
but even just one line to really hear
what the,
the will and the,
and the sense that the players are
giving to one line to really listen to
that and to actually be able to react to
it in a meaningful way is surprisingly
difficult.
Well,
that's difficult.
And,
and what happens is,
um,
if there's more than one current,
if they're conflicting currents onstage,
then you have to make a choice.
You have to either give in or insist.
And for the other musicians on stage,
if they sense two currents,
if they say for example,
if I show one thing and they hear a
response to that,
that is not in sync,
then they have a dilemma they have to
choose.
Do I go with what I see from the
conductor or do I go with what I hear?
And so I very often tell,
tell the orchestra's,
even the New York Philharmonic,
I say,
you know,
I really want you to play with my bead.
It's not that I care about.
You're following me that precisely.
It's just that I want to take the
element of choice out of the question so
that people are not forced to decide,
okay,
do I follow him or do I not follow him?
There has to be just one current.
Of course,
mistakes happen,
accidents happen.
If something goes wrong then you just
have to use your sense and that's based
on experience.
Either you given,
sometimes it's better to give in and
allow it to sort of write itself over
time.
Other Times you sort of dig your heels
in and you just say,
okay,
no,
this is where it is.
And it creates a discomfort,
an uncomfortable moment.
But,
um,
you try to use your best sense and,
uh,
I couldn't say it's a always one way or
it's,
or it's always another way is you just
have to figure out what the best way to
get out of those situations.
And hopefully they're not too frequent.